[MUSIC PLAYING]
DINO CHIESA: There's
no product or service
any company can build that
assures sustainable competitive
advantage.
Companies that adapt to changing
conditions survive and thrive.
The cycle of innovation
is ever faster.
Can your company learn
and adapt fast enough?
Hi, my name is Dena
Chiesa, and I'm
part of the Apigee
team at Google.
Application innovation
is an imperative.
Today, I'll explain the
central role APIs play
and how Apigee Edge
lets you manage
the APIs to power innovation.
You're part of a modern company.
You're embracing cloud
technologies more and more.
You know that's required.
You also know that to really
deliver business innovation,
you've got to connect to
partners better and build
ecosystems around
your offerings.
And to do that, you know
you've got to experiment.
You've got to adopt
agile business practices,
encourage and
cultivate fresh ideas,
measure the right
things, reward progress,
and you've got to act quickly.
The key technology that
enables all of this is APIs.
APIs power the modern
applications that
deliver innovation.
Want voice ordering?
Easy partner integration?
Context across
multichannel conversations?
Social login for users?
APIs enable all of those.
APIs are the mechanism for
building better experiences
for your users, whether they're
customers, partners, vendors,
or employees.
And agile business
has got to exploit
APIs to drive innovation,
and managing those APIs
is an imperative.
Today, I'm going to show
you how Apigee Edge works
to enable you to manage all
the APIs that power application
innovation for your business.
First, let's take a
quick look at what
you get with Apigee Edge.
There are three basic
categories of capability
in the API management platform.
Support for your
developer ecosystems
to let people discover
and understand your APIs
and rapidly build
applications that use them.
Second, monitoring
and analytics,
so that your API
program managers can
see which APIs are
being used and how,
or so that they can get
alerted when appropriate.
And third, an API
runtime, so that you
can expose usable, friendly,
efficient APIs that are secure.
In upcoming videos,
I'll walk you
through detailed demonstrations
of these three key capabilities
in the Apigee API
Management platform.
[MUSIC PLAYING]